[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
ich weiß dass ihr schnelle rezepte lebt
deswegen gibt es heute ein schnelles
rezept bei uns nicht gibt es nämlich
auch gleich mittagessen und zwar gibt es
seit ähnlichen späße mit erdnusssoße und
einem richtig leckeren glas modul salat
und das ganze rezept das dauert so etwa
25 bis 30 minuten also wirklich sehr
schnell und die ersten zutaten sich euch
zeigen weil das sind die zutaten für die
erdnusssoße und da könnt ihr wirklich
entscheiden ob ihr die erdnusssoße kalt
zubereitet oder wir doch ein paar ist
augen wollten das ganze noch ein
bisschen kocht aber wie gesagt es bleibt
euch überlassen ich sage euch mal die
zutaten für die erdnusssoße nämlich
etwas koriander irgendwo und eine
chilischote etwas limettensaft und club
18 dann könnt ihr entweder kernige also
diese stöckige oder cremige etwas butter
nehmen sojasoße ahornsirup und etwas
reißt es ich dann habe ich hier wasser
zum verdünnen und salz und pfeffer und
wie gesagt könnt ihr entweder jetzt alle
zutaten kalt verwenden oder ihr sorgt
für ein bisschen röstaromen und können
zum beispiel den ingwer und die
knoblauchzehen fein hacken und dann im
topf mit sesamöl das anbraten soweit ich
sitz machen ansonsten wie gesagt einfach
im mixer geben oder so kalt verrühren
und dann schmeckt es auch echt
hervorragend
[Musik]
und dann immer braucht ihr generell gar
nicht so schälen sondern könnt einfach
mit so einem kleinen löffel dieser
harten stellen hier wegnehmen und die
restliche schale die kann gerne auch
drauf bleiben die stört echt gar nicht
[Musik]
und wie gesagt könnt ihr jetzt die
zutaten einfach nur verrühren dann habt
ihr schon eine leckere erdnusssoße oder
ihr brate das ganze an ich nehme das
jetzt einfach ein bisschen sesamöl und
erhitzen sesamöl kann man auch super
hoch erhitzen und es eignet sich gut zum
anbraten deswegen nehme ich das jetzt
hier ganz gerne ansonsten einfach
weglassen und kalt vermischen aber ich
gerade jetzt kurz die irgendwann
knoblauchsland dann habe ich schön ist
tolles aroma
[Musik]
das war es jetzt auch eigentlich schon
wenn es gut duftet dürfte es gerne vom
hätte darunter zehn und dann einfach die
restlichen zutaten einrühren den
koriander werde ich ganz zum schluss
noch hacken und dazugeben ich muss sagen
ich selbst bin nicht so der koriander
fan aber zu solchen gerichten passt ganz
gut ich werde bis daraus dazu geben aber
nicht zufällig finde also mir schmeckt
oft einfach zu sein
jetzt einfach schöne sojasauce dazu
aaron sirup und
stehen es sich
wenn der topf jetzt nicht mehr so viel
restwärme habt könnt ihr die soße
nochmal auf kochen mit dem wasser
so wird nämlich die butter schön weich
und dann verbindet sich alles ganz gut
aber wie gesagt wir nicht kochen wollte
einfach ein mixer oder google stoppt
benutzen funktioniert auch gott
kennt ihr schon so lange den koriander
fein hacken
[Musik]
und dann habe ich jetzt hier noch den
limettensaft damit wird das ganze schön
geschmacklich abgerundet da schaut er
einfach mal je nach geschmack ein bis
zwei limetten und die chilischote gibt
ihr einfach nur dazu wenn ihr chili
vertrag wenn ihr sagt ok chili passt bei
uns ganz gut wenn er nicht so gerne
scharf ist oder zwei kinder mitessen
dann könnte es ihr fein hacken und dazu
servieren und dann kann sich ja jeder
spiele dazugeben nachgeschmack dass
jetzt auch schwarz einfach nur dazu
servieren
und das ganze jetzt hier noch
abschmecken
[Musik]
und dann ist die soße nämlich auch schon
fertig die stelle ich dann zur seite und
zeigt euch gleich die zutaten für den
glass nudelsalat und natürlich noch das
hähnchen dennig bereitet dazu noch ein
hühnchen zu und so eine erdnusssoße die
könnt ihr gerne auch in größerer menge
herstellen im kühlschrank lagern oder
sogar einfrieren und dann immer bei
bedarf einfach erwärmen in der
mikrowelle oder auf dem herd und dann
habt ihr immer eine frische erdnusssoße
dar
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier die weiteren
zutaten nämlich vier hähnchenbrustfilets
etwas da es im pfeffer und honig zu
machen hier habe ich glasnudeln die
werden gleich mit wasser übergossen
nochmal etwas koriander
frühlingszwiebeln limetten rote zwiebel
eine ananas die könnt ihr frisch oder
aus der dose verwenden maiskolben aus
und glas und hier habe ich noch
sojasauce etwas sesamöl ich habe ich nur
chilisoße also das süße soße und ein
paar kesha käme das hähnchen könnte
jetzt mit salz und pfeffer würzen und
falls ihr das ganze vegetarisch
zubereiten wollt könnt ihr zusammen
gemüse dazu grillen oder tofu verwenden
wobei ich sagen muss finanziert ofen
oder ihr könnt auch ein fisch zum
beispiel und ich würds und mariniert das
ganze jetzt auch mit etwas honig das
habe ich so eine leichte schöne süße
dabei
und dann einfach so ein bisschen
einmassieren
[Musik]
stelle ich das mädchen erstmal zur seite
die glasnudeln müssen einfach mit heißem
wasser übergossen werden und dann stellt
man sie zur seite und wir können dann
eben schön durchziehen
[Musik]
kurz zur seite und dann kann ich schon
mal die frühlingszwiebel nehmen und fein
hacken und wie gesagt ihr könnt die rote
zwiebel nehmen falls etwas nicht möglich
einfach weglassen
[Musik]
man könnte ein und ich wäre es schon
gewohnt mit den augen und in zwiebeln
aber jedes mal das gleiche naja ich
schon mal hier alles in eine große
schüssel
und meine community geben wir immer echt
viele tipps zum herausstrecken wasser in
moskau aber das getan anders natürlich
für euch was moderiert dann ist immer
ein bisschen schwierig naja ich finde im
glas und salat immer ganz lecker wenn
man diese maiskolben das so gibt aus dem
glas ich verbinde das so ein bisschen in
meiner kindheit weil meine schwester
denen salat immer gerne gemacht hat und
deswegen packe ich die hier noch mit
dazu
da lasse ich den koriander erst mal weg
und streut und später nur drauf aber was
ich hier gleich machen kann das ist
einmal die server soße
hier eingeben
und bisschen sesamöl und sojasauce
dann wird einfach nur noch alles fein
gehackt das heißt auch die cashewkerne
und limettensaft kommen noch dazu und
die glasnudeln gebe ich alles
[Musik]
und dann habe ich hier die glasnudeln
bereits abgegossen
ich glaube ich ihm gleich eine größere
chance bevor jetzt gleich wieder sauerei
macht und später sagen muss man hätte
auch gleich eine große schüssel nehmen
können nämlich lieber gleich eine große
schüssel ist man könnte mich hier alles
rein und schön miteinander verbunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann ist der salat ist man bereit da
fehlt noch die ananas und bei der ananas
könnt ihr wie gesagt entweder eine aus
der dose nehmen oder eine frische ananas
und bei der frisch und einfach drauf
achten wenn ihr hier oben diese blätter
ganz leicht raus bekommt dann ist das
schön reif ihr könnt jetzt tatsächlich
noch ein bisschen wobei die mittleren
blätter lassen sich echt gut lösen nur
die da aus nämlich du kannst also
überreif ist nicht aber sie hat eine
ganz gute reife und die könnte jetzt
gerne schneiden
entweder mit einem messer hier außen die
schale jetzt wegschneiden und dann den
rest würfeln oder ihr könnt auch ananas
schneider nehmen das mache ich mag aber
auch gerne mache ich das schöne
schreiben habe und die könnte dann
entweder roh dazugeben in kleine
stückchen oder ihr könnt sie gleich noch
mit anbraten
[Musik]
mir geht es hier einfach einmal
durchschneidet dann habt ihr gleich
schöne ananasscheiben
[Musik]
und wenn ihr sie nicht darum raten wollt
könnt ihr sie auch gleich in feine
stücke schneiden da gibt es zum beispiel
auch bei dem anderen als schneider so
diesen aufsatz man kann man das direkt
hier in die schüssel rein schneiden aber
ich werde es gleich noch anbraten das
heißt ich habe meine erdnusssoße fertig
habe den glasbläser fertig handys
mariniert ananasscheiben sind da und ich
kann das ganz schön anbraten
[Musik]
dabei ist ein glas nur salat schon
fertig und das hähnchenfleisch mariniert
und entweder könnt ihr jetzt drin auf
dem herz so breit oder im backofen zu
sagen ich bin mittlerweile ein großer
grill fan seit ich das backup kann ich
nämlich auch alleine da kann ich alleine
anfeuern da wo es nicht mehr dem rad
machen und wenn ich große sachen griller
oder eben viel zu bereiten nämlich gerne
das große ei für so kleine dinge nämlich
auch einfach mal gerne das kleine weil
ich da einfach schnell aufheizen kann
und wirklich einfach der spitze
zubereiten kann und ich habe hier schon
mal meine grillkohle rhein gegeben die
hat ja schön große und kleine stücke ist
erhitzt alles gleichmäßig und ich
brauche keinen grillanzünder mehr keine
sind die würfel nicht einfach den leiter
halt den rhein und kann damit anfeuern
sobald ich dann ein zwei flammen habe
kann ich das iphone verschließen da muss
ich nur darauf achten dass sie unten die
öffnung offen ist und auch hier oben
damit so eine art durchzug entsteht
jetzt bekommt das ganze schön feuerwehr
schönheit ich kann doch nach drinnen und
alles andere vorbereiten und kann dann
gleich wenn das ganze schön durch jetzt
ist hier noch mal die temperatur regeln
auf die perfekte gradzahl und da ist der
grill bereich
[Musik]
ich habe immer gesagt man kann bei jedem
wetter grillen aber sie wollten nicht so
recht aber egal jetzt habe ich den grill
heiß und es schmeckt auf jeden fall viel
viel besser
[Musik]
echt jetzt was ist denn das für ein
aprilwetter hier eben februar jetzt
regnet es auch noch regen sonne wind
wetter mit so kalt heute hier draußen
ich hab halt auch keine jacke mit egal
hähnchen ist fertig
was tut man nicht alles
was tut man nicht alles fürs essen
komm rein hat ihr seht ihr hat mich ja
früher auch für euch ich kann jetzt hier
den salat schon mal anrichten heute auf
morgen über probieren das auch ganz
schön und ich gebe jetzt die ananas mal
noch nicht dazu weil mein mann keine
süßen waren dinge in herzhaftem essen
mag deswegen gebe ich die anderen das
gleich bei mir noch mit dazu ich mag es
ganz gerne was ja auch recht gut passt
während roms also statt hähnchen einfach
schwimmen und ich glaube morath freut
sich gleich das ist endlich mal wieder
fleisch gibt an bord dann endlich war
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich schon nicht
mehr da war und und nicht einfach mal
beispiel ansicht einer kamera er war
immer da aber halt mal was einfach etwas
normales ist man also
vegan und und das ist ganz ganz
stinknormales
ist aber ich finde es jetzt man kommt
sich inzwischen auch richtig blöd vor
wenn irgendwas macht mit das stimmt ja
das stimmt ich finde es echt cool wenn
sie mit vegan ernährt und auch viel
fleisch verzichtet absolut in ordnung
aber gar nicht mehr erkennt dass ich
sagen würde ich nicht mal probieren ja
ich ja ich es aufgefallen wenn ich
einfach schöne hausmannskost ich habe
schon gedacht liegt an mir weiß ich habe
gedacht jetzt kommt er nicht mehr zum
essen irgendwas hat sich in der
beziehung verändert der will einfach
nicht mehr das was ich eben
zubereitetem essen was wir lange keinen
kontakt mehr hat
paquito maria bisher geschnitten ihr
könnt natürlich auch hähnchenspieße
machen und zu bereiten dann lege ich dir
dass du weißt du nichts machen gemacht
dass mama hat mit anderswo sieht sich
das ja nun mal einfach meine mutter hat
weg gemacht er hat einfach nudeln
gemacht und warum mache ich nudeln warum
haben wir keine normale wie andere
melodie der spitzel asiatisch angehaucht
aber kürzlich richtig schön einfach
schön ich denke jeder stehen maria dusl
machen
die richtigkeit
eine variation an ass awer och
hochzeitsmode kommen wir zeigen hier mal
die schöne herzlos oder jacqueline juli
aus der schweiz
kennedy war gab ich kenne keinen oder
die gardine liegt macht man sich
bezeichnet ist kommen die hier
als in schwaben sind des oberschwaben
oberschwaben firma buck heißt dieser ist
keine produktplatzierung kein geld dafür
bekommen aber das ganz ganz toll nudeln
normale nudeln keine glasnudeln bei
glaskugeln glasknochen natürlich müssen
angst richtig gemocht hast du
assoziationen
ich finde es schmeckt halt wenn man was
auf dem grill zubereitet schmeckt
zeitgleich ganz anderes deswegen habe
ich mich heute nach draußen an die
antarktis begeben werde dich zum kochen
und grillen
und was sagst du dir ganz kanzler
schmidt ich gut aber ich glaube mit
minute hätte es besser
barilla die sind nicht so hoch glaubt
mir
jetzt googeln sie alle war aber da gab
es den skandal jetzt mal man muss man
und apple
und das ist vor allem ein gericht die
den glaspalast dann könnte auch galt es
mit schweizer geheiratet hat ist es
wieder gott
sei dank eine faire entscheidung hätte
ich schlimmer treffen können
ich möchte schon die einflüsse von der
schweizer nummer aber die marken nicht
fest habt ihr was böses zeigt ich glaube
also falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt ihr findet in meiner app und auf
dem blog auf facebook de wie gesagt das
ist eigentlich und 20 minuten gericht
gut draußen habe noch gegrillt
normalerweise hätte ich jetzt einfach
den grill an gemacht dann alles
zubereitet und dann ist da irgendwas ist
anders ja es ist cool sind auch es ist
ganz toll es ist wirklich es menschen
ein rasch koreaner und liebstes ebay
lakritze ja ich mag es nicht eben
übermaß also ein bisschen zu hören darf
ich dann mein tipp geben ja und zwar
wenn ein mannheimer seit und essen geht
da gibt es die games mmore in jennys
heißt es das heißt es ist so ein
indonesisches laden und da müsst ihr
unbedingt rinderfilet streichen mit
koriander und panna blätter limo trinken
ist nicht teuer da wo ich richtiges
nicht oder glaubt mir 13 90 ich weiß
nicht was das ok also weil sie meinen
mannheim seite folgt memories in jennys
ich kann mit marmor als französisch
chinesische also für mir leid wenn ich
mal was cool ist super und falls ihr
weitere rezept wünsche habt für schnelle
gerichte dann schreibt auch gerne
ich habe noch bis auf 1 3
[Musik]